vers vous xavier xavier chemy soeur
discours évidemment très fort du
président ukrainien qui demandent à
l'union européenne de choisir et de
défendre l'ukraine en l'acceptant dans
os en son sein
touchant émouvant on retiendra bien sûr
les mots du président zine ski on
retiendra aussi ce point levé et ce
sourire
qui est une marque un peu de fabrique
depuis ces cinq jours de deux d'intenses
combats entre
l'ukraine et les troupes russes à chaque
fois le président est né ce qu'ils
essaient de montrer cette détermination
cette fois ci c'est face à l'union
européenne qu'il l'a fait en rappelant
que s'il intervenait sans notes c'était
aussi parce que jusqu'ici il y avait eu
peut-être beaucoup de boue discours de
part et d'autre et que et bien ses
discours n'était pas forcément aller
plus loin cette fois ci il il demande
effectivement un encouragement de la
part à deux de l'union européenne c'est
ces termes sont un peu moins fort que ce
qu'ils ont pu être hier lorsqu'il
demandait une adhésion immédiate car la
procédure était à ses yeux juste et
possible juste là dessus les pays de
l'union européenne semblait tout à fait
d'accord possible les la situation et le
fonctionnement de l'union européenne en
termes d'adhésion peuvent être un peu
plus compliqué que ce que vous voyez
jusqu'ici le le président ukrainien ce
qui est sûr c'est que oui il a demandé
et bien de l'aide une reconnaissance de
la part de l'union européenne il a
rappelé et bien que le pays était là
pour défendre aussi des valeurs et ça ça
n'est pas anodin des valeurs de liberté
des valeurs de droits de l'homme ce qui
a énormément ému et dans l'hémicycle et
je pense nous mêmes ici ici en plateau
on rappelle que le pays combat depuis
cinq jours le président et minsky qui a
mis en avant les citoyens les plus
courageux qui dit que l'ukraine a fait
son choix celui de l'adhésion et
souhaite que l'union lui confirmer bien
son souhait de d'entrer dans l'union
merci beaucoup xavier schmith avoue
rester